bebut oh god oh god
oh good runs a crime oh god why there's
so many back to chicken show me guide me
veteran of minecraft where are you oh my
god I'm up above you I think Jack where
are we or plane crash honey we I don't
even have a skin yet oh man upper ode
what is it called important I won yeah
like default skin t44 skins are the new
meta okay I'm gonna dunk on some babies
in this game wait why why are we up here
what are we doing so I don't know what
this is either but we're gonna play
survival but the world is amplified so I
think it's like crazy structures it's
time you see there's like an island in
the sky over there yeah more more okay
minecraft gods cuz I'm on ok I'm sorry
am i able to jump off into that water
tower do you think I'll make it light
died completely if I try that is
tempting that that is some I enjoyed how
about you jump first I'll give you a
push PewDiePie pushes jacksepticeye off
the cliff oh did you really
he doesn't sound like you made it he
can't even aim for this distance I eat
like shaved at the edge who's so close
you're gonna have a sprint
bro bro
Oh
epic minecraft minecraft thanks
I didn't swore I didn't swore I didn't I
tried to high-five you didn't always say
okay Jackson it's gonna be nice we have
to prepare our boot our home together
really living we roommate we roommate we
built crib also since this is start of
new let's play I give you this here you
go Oh magic flowers I eat no I can't
I'm going to die my belly red oh my gosh
okay where are we going I don't actually
have a plank where you need to find like
a good good place right fine be as
always he just dig straight down and
live in a hole but like an ostrich
exactly hide your head in the sand so
I'm gonna go to the middle sheep sweet
little sheep know me well oh my god do
we killed who we take wool Macbeth we he
give flour to she be in this you burn
what is wrong with her faces ah never
mind
there no more there you go I give a I
give him flour to a chicken okay he just
run this is the hardcore mode of playing
mine crime be nice to ever whoa whoa
whoa whoa this world is crazy Jack wait
what just melting the whole forest
already that's that's like just don't go
near the lana you will die okay there's
a forest fire as well my god global
warming even take over minecraft my god
this says so much about our planet
there's gotta be just a floating in the
air yeah it's so weird
what five out of eight robot that's okay
can't you minecraft to eat in real life
there's a huge waterfall over here and
well sight of the cliff is just water
god damn place is weird yeah it's cool
I'm glad this isn't my world my world is
peaceful as dogs in it you give on dogs
already yeah I would say spoil ease but
episode already go up how come whenever
we record together I just turn it to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
to do this is it's not even my accident
no it's
it's just a weird voice do I plant tree
help in vitam oh my god we had give back
with solve global warming look big happy
dead
the fire will go away now don't kill Pig
not killing a petting with flower I'm
petting to get meat good piggy what'd
you do to pig
I did nothing to pig he just explode and
give me his flesh sister where are we
going we need a plan it's gonna be night
time we're gonna die immediately least
you're eating while you're gaming
alright how you know I'm real gamer at
least we have waterfall to help climb oh
look at us already minecraft veterans
even though you've you've been playing
it for a whole month
at this point up I go see you later
mortal I have reached the source okay
alright okay good idea
are you ready to take this seriously now
I'm ready there's a waterfall next to
lava for love of waterfall we can make
cobbles ideon we can make a cobblestone
generator spawn wait here's the ocean
actually that might be good like we stay
by the beach yeah just like Brighton
just like Brighton we're relieved oh you
think I can jump on cloud it's catch
maybe you like okay chop wood let's go
three two one shop shop shop shop shop
shop felix has played a lot of Minecraft
now Jackson he's starting he can teach
him so much you shop wood shop shop shop
shop shop shop little man oh wow okay I
dare you to hit I dare you to hit the
pool down there yes I take all your
things they're mine now
Jack Jack yes
are you gone forever what are you I'm at
the bottom of pool I survived oh my god
how you jumped so well because I good I
play minecraft
we haven't done anything okay okay okay
I'm buddy I might a double waterfall so
all my knee
there's creepers Oh Jack Oh God
minecraft scary time now I hate this
this game is legitimately sky no no told
me like oh this stupid kids game I'm
creepy oh I kill sheep now remember when
it was my suggestion that we should play
in hardcore mode you're the first to die
oh god can you come to the double llama
I mean the why don't the double
obviously with lava right now it's
really freaking fer me okay
I hit back I'm at forest fire okay I
think I hear you
ah it's a creeper maybe we should show
me your name all the time you could
always look up did he hear that
explosion no then you know it must be
close if you don't hear it that's mean
you know really that means you're deaf
now from explosion you cannot hear it
are you splashing in water no I don't
wanna go too far in case we end up going
I one of us should really stay in one
place this is like getting lost at the
store okay mom
I'm sorry I take serious haha I will
find you don't worry I'm at a forest
fire though the trees are burning
I get more wood okay so I am at - 183
thanks I'm at - 169 whoa that is bad
number is not a swore you saw I have to
punch you there let me fight you didn't
sward know it's fake I'm at - - OH - now
I'm we should be pretty close to each
other then I'm minus 160 okay you went
past me impossible
and then okay what's your Z then o my Z
is minus 354 - 220 Oh God
I have to go yeah yeah go down I'm gonna
die from falling out this alright yeah
I'm getting better
you're minus 200 230 40 okay
I see you Jackie there you are - yeah
you look changed you look different
that's not me if it's fake back my god
it's a fake Jack he swore you know we
should have built the house by now we
should have like pickaxe we shouldn't
start mining we should have a diamond
pickaxe by now okay - 200-some be
zombies I run run run I hope my creepy
doesn't get me okay so - turn is 63
about two giant waterfall again
tarantulas it creepy oh I'm starving so
I can't run way scream I hear you jack
Wow alright I got it I got it I kill
myself to it and then will spawn sings
black genius maybe we should back out
and not do like such a crazy world
because it's kind of what do you think
yeah this is this is way too vertical
dang it okay so default and we call it
no it doesn't count epic sward just
because you're not in the server doesn't
mean you can't swore no lets me no one
can join it's reset oh it's [ __ ]
annoying type of voice to make entire -
Scandinavians lost in Minecraft is this
even Scandinavian yes of course this is
how my parents speak when I board helmet
Oh swore it is good oh good swore hey
high five high five Sheep - the Sheep
sheep - bye hi back she white - father
my unit I buy back huh oh he's giving me
flesh he offer flesh does where sheep go
now I can high-five with the Sheep
high-five now you can high-five sheep
with sheep Wow
is this crazy minecraft thanks not use
it great whoa
okay so we should play maybe should we
play seriously
okay maybe like before the Sun goes then
we want at least have a house right okay
I get would you get I get would you get
wait but what do I do
maybe you get hurt maybe hurt I make
crafts Finch and we both can utilize but
we have to share share care sharing are
caring good God you I got
can I have one would I make some plain
you know I don't need it with what
everyone needs a quid oh it's special
wood is special wood for special people
okay I need more anymore I used up all
wood to make stick for some reason I
[Music]
make stick for later I'm still I'm not
new but I'm still stupid make this crap
again oh I need a break for I'd see crap
okay I'll make wooden pickaxe that's
good
remember to replant tree to save
environment I'm all about minecraft baby
okay I think this is a physical blinks
actually good look look fellow
Scandinavian there is a little feud here
we can stay in flue-cured already lost
you friend's name already disappear any
lost boy we walk around each other
battle to death question mark
why /n
okay okay maybe maybe just give little
tap
talk a little sister okay please hit
once out of system okay now we safe
maybe little stone here oh this could be
our little mind oh you and there's no
maybe good timing oh I'm more advanced
than you you small brain I be polite if
you don't get there soon you're going to
be smart all right I will get diamond
before you probably right you know what
to do a brain took me two took me two
hours yesterday to get your small work
and it stops you I was watching some of
your after I like played some of it
myself yet I went back and watched like
your first episode your spawn was nuts
was it really you got so many like good
things you might like people and you you
went down you got diamonds really
quickly because I'm trying because I'm
veteran Jack no cuz you sheet I know you
should say I shake but your shake always
do not cool - [ __ ] cool I like that
did you get any okay okay we now we got
to make a little smelting machine you
have cobblestone Oh
Copley I got here you take this are you
ready for epic epic time boom what did
smell te what did you do yeah we need
coal can i oh what you can't smell it -
smell yeah I did that in my episode
everyone was like you did you did it
wrong but you still got the same answer
you know that cool wood also burn inside
it now they yeah see I teach Sam gamers
teach each other even though I'm still
using my hands - okay you're quite
hardware I get iron pickaxe stop
advancing aaron ages before me
yeah nose-mounted ma'am oh my god is he
allergic to smoke
damn honestly we got sealed pretty fast
we should speedrun this beat dragon
first episode I don't even know what
dragon is spoiling spoil East oily so
sorry about that bro I only got to
nether realm and then got scared and
came back yeah first time they around
was like no hey III got my thing and
then I got obsidian I was like I
probably shouldn't be okay we need coal
cuz I can't make torches okay why don't
we make this our mind then and we
started mining down just like it because
we both have Steel X that's what I do
look I do already
Oh it'sit's not steel it's iron okay
Edie of course sorry
it's iron hey come on but we don't have
torch I steered you got the man up my
cookies no you got the men I meet cooker
you got two men I need I need sustenance
to get low but where you get to meet
people like Jack and Felix should really
play Minecraft together than his not
like this I can't see anything Jack I
don't understand why it dark okay I kill
sheep and then get won't Macbeth maybe
ask sheep for a call
Oh sheep whoa I found the shaft right
away dude
really how do you do that I don't know
I'm gonna call you shaft from now call
me chef Orion what is the spooky sounds
that keeps happening I'm scared I think
it's when a monstrous pawns in a kid but
I'm not sure no holy fully freak eats
Mickey all right I see you see the cold
no it's not it's next to the llama me
scared of lavador hey careful
what are you don't be hero in Minecraft
the rule there's a chest here bread
tonight we eat gamer have you got
pumpkin a melon seeds and a name tag
which means if we find a pet we can name
it something also how that works yes oh
my god have any song you're learning
you're throwing crafts you're improving
its person honestly we're pretty lucky
from finding that so fast
I think maybe epic gamer we play games
Jesus love almost kept me hey hey hey
danger danger stranger danger we don't
have armor backup Rebecca are you ready
for epic I put torch everybody
do you have sword right yeah maybe I'm
in the wallet
go back okay I find I find they back my
thoughts I can get well yes we grab them
right did you want any steel yeah you
stole I made the stone you swipe dog
give me give me all my things
maybe we should cover up his lava I feel
like yeah let's see so what do you want
hands put you one for me I don't have
how can he slap
how can you sled okay so you had the
iron pickaxe yeah there you go these sir
and the me some more in that gray wool
and the thing and the sword and the
shovel and the thing and I and I have
second pickaxe should we explore this
right away I don't know uh I don't know
how epic do you want to be I don't want
to blow people's minds dude this place
is mess evasive that is great great just
great projecting
Jeepers Creepers oh did he get the shiny
I got everything from check again oh oh
man
okay do we need more call this
co-sleeper down need to smelt these
multi so a minecraft tip is to place
torch on left side so when you go back
you look at other side and you're like
oh this where I come from or just find
diamond right away now how is so so
smart I know you're thinking and how are
you so at remind another hole it could
do this mine is insane
there's a wiser there's a sheep here I
mean for what are they called chicken
[Music]
what this freaking most common meat
animal he can be friends we don't have
okay wait let's bury him here
stay stay here suffocate the little
cheapy stay we come back very soon
oh there's lava lava down here lava and
water maybe we shouldn't go down too far
yeah I'm scared mom I don't have any
what level are around 21 if we go down
10 more steps we could find diamond
right away which would be kind of good
mean okay let's go together let's go
down here okay watch out for creepers
I'm nervous
that's not the pro gamer tip that I
learned Jack you press f3 and it says 11
this is the level I already learned I
get diamond to myself on level 12 oh you
know how you know this I know how can
you know this because because it took me
2 hours and I had to look up how okay
well I guess not there cuz I thought
level people might get them 11 12 I
thought that meant you go down 12 love
oh no trying to count from make the
water level be like okay if I go down 1
2 3 4
why not work we probably should like get
steel and sink get some armor before we
go down here yeah do that I have I have
12 so I could probably make a couple of
6 iron ores now it is steel well giant
water pot lapras place that's what I say
that waterfall and thing down here we
should even look at first diamond blue
that's not time indeed laughs it's blue
what color diamond time in this e3 I
meant clear like your ocean high so
thank you you're sweet Scandinavian I
noticed my eyes thank you it's the first
thing I see when I wake up in the middle
nice look at well this looks like a
shrine room dude
what is this you should build our base
here yeah that's awesome
this is like an evil lair yeah I'm
scared maybe we go back I like that you
put down torch even though lava here
brighten up everything be quiet
oh look we found obsidians that turtles
spawn obsidians
diamond okay well I guess no lucky ducky
but we find what this rights don't
actually do you kids not like to trigger
mechanism you can make should we bring
sheep to surface no okay you can make
like wires and electrical components and
epicness contraptions contractions yes
like the ones your mother have hey don't
talk about good mama septic I like oh
wait where's our way out
not there I can talk normal now it's
been too long
I'm just talking monkey help me Jack
help me aren't you hungry I have bread
for you hi I have meat bro maybe we
should have built a little house here
where we check where is our thing here
but we can make a new one maybe here
it's nice but why would we put here and
then not move Oh what is that what is
big tall black figure over there okay
should we kill him we now will probably
die it's too dangerous
I don't know if I just boy like suffer
you don't know yet I just do that oh
Jesus okay I found secret mining place
from creeper creepers our friends just
go over and give them a hug do not hurt
you if you nice that's the pro trip tip
trip we are taking poacher God know what
I feel about having someone point out
how dumb I am all the time where are you
are you by the thing yeah I really feel
like it should show our names a bit
further than it is right what should we
build next we should definitely make
armor so just melt as much iron as
possible I would say I do I have
beetroot seeds a pumpkin seeds we can
make a farm and make epicness do you
have any coal could you put that in this
one it's in the furnace what did you
make a second one just so we can burn
faster okay and then I do this look Punk
oh we we put the Oh Jack I put
everything that I don't have
/ surprise for you train go very fast
you have to be careful though speed
these keys reduce the activation okay I
I also have this look wait how do I drop
everything at once
damn it was in chest dude all I can do
is think about Minecraft lately that's
all you need it's the best and now we
played together whole new world okay go
inside and I push you down okay stay
[Music]
it's like Disneyland for free happy you
made a armor in your I make metal pants
now metal pants like shiny metal look at
my shiny metal ass
sorry it was out I'm sorry well metal
pants almost look like apron you ready
to cook little boy okay I can't make
anything else I'm melting more it's okay
it's okay
I'll make us helmets and then one was
we're ready we're gonna distraction I
can't wait to destruction
oh it's morning time look morning
morning we should actually I know this
sounds really pretentious but we should
actually place our house so we see the
sunset okay I like that
that's not pretentious wait which is
better sunrise or sunset they I think
they go in bow
no wait we want sunset sorry yeah yeah
sunset okay jack here you go now we both
look very big rained a big helmet
because big brain yes
big cube brain okay well now I think we
should melt all of it let's see what's
left three more maybe we make a ayran
sword
I want to shield oh Camry yeah we should
probably do a show yeah we can make
cousins are so annoying I'll make you
want
I have epic whoa wooden sword no no no I
got you okay how much iron did you have
I grabbed as much as I could that was
the point that was plantation I'm sorry
I sighs oh we have to name tags let's
listen we're doing good man the power of
friendship when you work together you
mind together gamers help each other we
are too strong there's no other video
games in 2019 this is the only one that
mattered
can you believe minecraft invented video
games okay now the boys go down and we
are not afraid boys mine boys mine no
girls allowed down here we should
explore the mineshaft by a chef mind
what is called Minecraft should be
gratis we can make epic rollercoaster
sure what's best item - Oh pickaxe to
good pickaxe to strong maybe we should
close off like areas that we maybe judge
Oh
should make you up absolutely kill
absolutely welcome to our town and now
we with sweet land let's close this up
so we know I usually cut down the
pillars too because they make it really
confusing
do I need X it's preferable I don't have
then don't
okay got it big break very very okay I
get all cold just so we have and I feel
like I'm actually doing yeah what are we
searching for exactly um there could be
a spawner there could be more chests I
think is the main issue our main thing
with the shadows and just like exploring
it see what's in this you mean have a
little fun time little fun time in
little
Minecraft's nothing nothing here you
didn't you did not okay I closed off
then close close and then what about
here Steve I'm stickin spider Oh monster
acient
Judaism oh wow oh oh
Jack you fallin hurt i fallen made
poopoo
help me Oh No Oh Oh scary skinny what
take a teleporter behind you
he shot me I'm not today thank you
Oh creeper ISM whoa we found a spotter
that's awesome holy Frick I never found
even in my own weight they're poisoned
run Jack run minecraft is a scary game
for not babies I thought it was a
regular spotter dang it well he's scared
now oh he running away he backing up in
the water there's a creeper ism down
there and I'm worried
hey creeper what's your name oh man how
did you do that if you have the shield
your protection wait why is it bright
here Oh
good question lava buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
what this what happened put this down
here Oh scary oh whoa
it continues to shat oh good you are so
good I found gold it wait what wait
really
I found chicken place it all connects to
chicken
wait what yeah this is River before Oh
more gold it's iron pepper epic chest
over here Oh guys don't know God Oh run
yeah
oh god why there's so many to get back
to chicken the goal the hell is
happening
but the goal mommy should not have come
in here without any food
[Music]
can you handle Oh God Oh God okay I
don't want to jump into your zone
because I am afraid I'll end up hitting
me oh god I'm gonna die
you have one heart okay let me get them
[Music]
oh the golden are grabbity cold cold
cold cold time epic cold time should we
leave
maybe we should not be greedy maybe we
should be strong strong like the Vikings
of our forefathers forefathers were like
hey let's not be [ __ ] wait sorry
where do we come from this is epic way
out I do little hope to get out we
should end do it making bed okay but
then we have to kill sheep I kill sheep
now no we don't I'm not killing them I'm
putting them to sleep okay I also coach
sleep okay and maybe I just killed it'll
piggy he smells so good he smell good I
have to kill I'm a vegetarianism real
life but in Minecraft like everything is
killable our home very pretty
ok let's make bed ok yeah I have I have
three wool and ok ok let's place down
the bed I don't think it's gonna be
nighttime for a bit exam the Sun is way
high in this case thing it's ok I cook
ok let's get some food and we wait does
the sleeping reset your health now it
just resets the day I like how now I'm
doing a survival let's play with you and
I'm doing my own survival let's play the
springtime well I guess I'll I'll be do
the same technically do you have more
coat could you put it on the the other
one no it's all the coal ahead oh wait I
have would freak so that was like a
villager that turned zombie before I
don't know if you saw that guy who
looked like weird
oh they're corrupted yeah I think it was
I think that's quite rare I don't know
but I find bunches of them in my place
room Oh Sun setting Sun setting time for
bed I'm just want to get to sleep the
way you gotta place your own bed I don't
have a bed whoa I gave you my wall to
make your bed ah you know what this
means we have to shoot you
to share bed with me nothing minecraft
only real life okay
I sleep back now my bed no wait why
can't the nut make the bed a regular bed
come on we need to make bed I'd I'd look
for sheep oh so very darkness bear if
target Oh get acquired how does it work
when you sleep in multiplayer actually
yeah I don't know I kill Pig because
cows ease and creepies and she pees
destroy the beat them all you have to
kill the mannequin but there's a scary
scary man's killing me okay I think I
have it I also kill sheep excellent
retreat
I don't remember warehouse just keep
running again follow the moon and then
bed okay I got it
okay I need to put up like a barrier
against these you mean like building
house yes you make barrier very good
they stick out I'm not fast okay
take that oh no another one
[Music]
man trying look you can jump on bed you
know this it's balanced fans Wow alright
gamers hope you enjoy first episode
smash like if you want more a million
million double million likes and more
episode and several beds for you
good night gamers good night sleep tight
top of night storm of the night what you
never played to / simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try
and then you can tell me if it's good or
not not convinced yet okay I'll cut you
a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]